are you going to burning man this time
i'm not i mean i have kids right now i
just want to be around them my wife was
being so cool about it and she knows i
love burning man she's like go to
burning man and i was gonna go and then
i just i just want to be around my
kids as much as i can right now but i've
never been to burning man so i don't
know how secretive it is
that i mean because quite high-profile
folks go yeah everyone knows elon musk
goes there
isn't it pretty open got a boat
you know that
the boat you know there's a it's called
art cars they all make art cars and like
part of the
part of the burn what's so beautiful
about it is like
you can't buy anything there man like
you you i'd i've heard
i don't know if this has changed
it's been a bit because of the pandemic
but
the only thing you could buy was ice and
coffee
and i think maybe that's changed i heard
some whisper that that's changed but
so
that means that
it's a gifting economy is what they call
it and so
people will just give you stuff talk
about having a struggle with deserving
stuff man what are you gonna [ __ ] do
when the camp next to you
is like every morning making the best
iced coffee that you've ever had in your
life and they just are giving it all
away till it's all gone what are you
gonna do it's
it's the best
ever and then you're giving things to
people and then you you learn stuff like
you learn these really interesting
lessons like uh
one of the times i went there
got all these uh
strawberries might not sound like a big
deal but
when you're out there in the dust and
you're not at one of like the like
hardcore like luxury camps which do
exist out there
you know you've got these like items
where in my mind i'm like yeah these are
gonna be just for me and my girlfriend
my special stash of fruit and this or
that and then like
two days in
you're walking around your camp
with the strawberries that you were
coveting and everyone's so happy to get
like cold strawberries and you've
realized oh my god this feels so much
better than the way a strawberry tastes
so you learn
something experientially there uh which
is an incredible thing
it's an incredible thing um man now i'm
wishing i'd decide to go to burning man
have you been a few times yeah
i just know like
uh at least people were saying it was
elon musk's boat like yeah like this i
think it was like a it's like this
massive it's art cars and it was this
party on this thing you could just
anyone
can go
on the boat like no one's like there's
no guest list
you just go on there i never saw him
there but that you know everyone's
whispering elon musk is here there's a
secrecy there's all that kind of stuff
because you probably have to respect
that but the same time there it seems
like the kind of people that go there
i mean
the the rules of the outside world are
suspended
in the sense that
the um
the crime the aggression
the tensions all that seems to dissipate
somehow not all the way
not all the way there you know there's a
you could look it up you know because
like there is tension there's a lot of
tension there between
um
it's called plug-in plays like you know
burning man like the history of burning
man is
fascinating it has its roots
in
the cacophony society is what it was
called which is a
sort of evolution of something that was
i think it was called the
god like the san francisco basically
there was like an art movement in san
francisco and i can't remember the name
of it maybe the suicide club or
essentially like
they were really into urban exploration
and uh meaning like breaking into like
old
abandoned buildings and stuff but part
of this
what this was was
you would prepare your life
as though you were going to kill
yourself you would get all your affairs
in order you would get so it's going
back to what we were talking about with
a cancer diagnosis you're like sort of
putting yourself into
that world of like i'm going to get all
my affairs together as though this is it
and then there was some i'm sorry for
anyone listening if i'm butchering this
but i think there was some really cool
initiation where they would blindfold
you and they would take you into some of
these abandoned buildings and you didn't
know where you were walking but they
would say like if you take one step
to the left you're gonna die
you're gonna fall off you're gonna fall
so please be careful so you're like
in the moment and then blindfold comes
off it's a big awesome party this
evolves into something called the
cacophony society there's a great book
called tales of the cacophony society
for people listening
um
you know one of the uh
members of the cacophony society was the
author of fight club and so if you've
seen fight club like you could see
little ideas that were in the cacophony
society they were into
dadaism which i don't know a lot about
like i don't know it's but it's a
philosophical art movement
um
and then so
basically what was happening is like
they kept burning increasingly large
effigies
in san francisco
and they weren't allowed to do it and so
they took it out in the desert and
they were basing it on something called
a zone trip which is like you know
across this border
the rules of that old society are gone
and so
that was the original
burning man which was
these lunatics
out in the desert
launching like burning pianos out of
catapults
through the air doing like drive-by
shooting ranges like
no rules
wild magical beautiful insane madness
and then
it grew and grew and grew and grew until
you have burning man as it is today
which is still the most incredible thing
i mean obviously anytime you have like a
thing that's been around for a while
you're gonna get that it's not like it
used to be it's not as free as it used
to be so this or that but what's
fascinating about burning man someone
pointed this out to me
look on the ground
no trash
no cigarettes
the ethic of like picking up your [ __ ]
there is like so intense so it's not
like the other festivals you go to where
there's just trash everywhere [ __ ]
scattered everywhere
it's clean people are picking up their
stuff
people are like
really being conscious of like not
[ __ ] up the playa so i'm sorry don't
stop and you don't get a burner yapping
about burning man they we won't stop
it'll get mourning but there's a power
there but there is a power to culture uh
propagating itself through to the
stories that we tell each other and that
holds up
uh for burning man that like it's clear
that the culture has stayed strong
throughout the years yes there's so many
people so many
really interesting people
uh
speak of burning man as like a
a sacred place they go to to to remind
themselves about what's important yes
that's so interesting and it is and it
is i mean it's like you know there are
all these stories of like i love guru
stories i have a guru neem crowley baba
never met him he was rambasa's guru at
least not in the flesh but the story of
the guru is if you're lucky
you meet this being that
and we're not talking about you know
whatever the run-of-the-mill like
charlatans out there like i know for
sure that people
are in the world right now who
uh
when you're around them
you the thing you're talking about the
affirmation of
the potential of humanity and also just
an acceptance of yourself and
you know cultivate like seeing someone
who's cultivated
uh love or compassion or whatever but in
this way that is
i mean you would almost
you would rather me that being than like
a ufo land in your backyard it's like it
is the ufo it's a person but it's not
it's
everybody and nobody and somehow they
like
end up
conveying to you
ideas that you may have heard a million
times before but somehow within the
language itself is a transmission that
permanently
alters you and so these people exist
i think you could argue that burning man
the
the total thing
is a guru that a pilgrimage is involved
to get there
you
like it's not easy to get there and when
you get there
it's
it's gonna teach you something
it's to show you something it's going to
and what maybe some of the stuff it
shows you might not be great but the
community
around you
will like
will
hold you as you're like
whatever the thing is that's coming out
of it is coming out of you and even the
simplest activities the simplest
exchange of words have uh like just like
with the gurus
a profound impact somehow yeah something
about that place yeah
not to mention the insane
synchronicities like
insane synchronicities here and i think
like
you know to get back to the notion of
sentience is a
byproduct of
harmonized yet hyper complex system um
see i think synchronicities like
like those kinds of systems are like
lightning rods for synchronicity so
cr crazy not just because you're high
synchronicities
happen that are impo that are impossible
where you just have to deal with it and
and like you'll need something and
within a few minutes someone's like oh
here you here you go
you